la situación del ex mandatario brasileño
de extrema derecha Jair bolsonaro luego
de la toma de las sedes de los tres
poderes del estado en Brasil es incierta
bolsonaro viajó a la Florida en Estados
Unidos el 30 de diciembre evadiendo la
ceremonia de traspaso de poder a sus
rival izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva pero tras los hechos del domingo
en Brasil no hay información oficial
sobre el expresidente un hospital de
Orlando Florida donde se reportó que
estaba internado lo desmintió mientras
que en Washington el portavoz del
departamento de estado Estados Unidos
net price afirmó que todo individuo que
haya entrado a la nación norteamericana
con una visa diplomática y ya no está
ejerciendo funciones debe abandonar el
país
un visado tipo a está reservado para
alguien que se dedica a asuntos
oficiales en los Estados Unidos en
nombre de su gobierno
si ese ya no es el caso corresponde a
esa persona en particular solicitar un
cambio en su estado migratorio a un tipo
diferente de visa
luego de su derrota en las urnas
bolsonaro atacó al tribunal supremo y a
las instituciones democráticas y tras el
asalto de manifestantes bolsonaristas en
Brasilia la justicia inició
investigaciones que podrían encontrar
responsable al ex presidente sin embargo
hasta el momento las autoridades
brasileñas no han pedido oficialmente
una extradición
allegados a bolsonaro tratan de
desvincularse El ocurrido el 8 de enero
como es el caso de su sobrino Leonardo
indio bolsonaro
manifestaciones pacíficas y ordenadas
siempre serán bienvenidas pero
infelizmente por culpa de algunos
infiltrados y alborotadores presenciamos
escenas lamentables durante las
manifestaciones en La Explanada el
Ministerio de Justicia de Brasil
calificó la toma de la capital como un
crimen de golpe de estado